let me explain why you don't need the
biggest and best computer to create
motion design in After Effects many
people believe that you need a high-end
computer with lots of processing power
and a powerful GPU to create motion
design in After Effects but the truth is
you only need a fast CPU clock speed and
a decent amount of ram to get the job
done while a powerful GPU can help with
some tasks it's not necessary for most
motion design work after effects
primarily relies on the CPU for
processing power so a fast CPU clock
speed is essential ideally you want at
least 32 to 64 gigs of RAM however 16
gigs can work just fine for smaller
projects you also don't need a brand new
machine in fact you can create amazing
work on a relatively older computer as
an example it's currently 2023 and I'm
personally working day to day on a 2017
iMac so don't let the myth of needing a
super computer hold you back with a fast
CPU and a decent amount of ram you have
everything you need to create amazing
motion design in After Effects